In August, Congress passed the Paws Act, puppies assisting wounded service members, directing the Department of Veterans Affairs to begin a pilot program to fund service dogs for veterans with post-traumatic stress disorder. It's a reflection of an emerging field of research that is finding that trained service dogs can help people cope with post-traumatic stress disorder. The VA is not the only place interested in the power of animals to help heal and comfort humans. In recent years, therapy dogs have shown up in hospitals, on college campuses at exam time, and even in offices, where management is looking for ways to reduce workers' stress.
In August, Congress passed the Paws Act, puppies assisting wounded service members, directing the Department of Veterans Affairs to begin a pilot program to fund service dogs for veterans with post-traumatic stress disorder. It's a reflection of an emerging field of research that is finding that trained service dogs can help people cope with post-traumatic stress disorder. The VA is not the only place interested in the power of animals to help heal and comfort humans. In recent years, therapy dogs have shown up in hospitals, on college campuses at exam time, and even in offices, where management is looking for ways to reduce workers' stress.|||今年八月，国会通过了《PAWS 法案》（即“小狗协助受伤军人”法案），指示退伍军人事务部启动一项试点计划，为患有创伤后应激障碍的退伍军人提供资助服务犬的经费。这反映了一个新兴的研究领域，该领域发现经过训练的服务犬可以帮助人们应对创伤后应激障碍。退伍军人事务部并不是唯一对动物治愈和安慰人类的力量感兴趣的机构。近年来，治疗犬出现在医院、考试期间的大学校园里，甚至出现在管理层寻找减少员工压力方法的办公室中。
At the same time, though, emotional support animals have become a favorite butt of late-night TV jokes, conjuring images of people boarding planes with peacocks and hamsters in tow. So what does the research say about the effectiveness of animal-assisted therapy? When can animals help reduce distress and improve our mental health? health. What's the difference among service animals, therapy animals, and emotional support animals? What's backed by research and what is not? And what about regular household pets? How do our companion animals affect our health and well-being? Do our pets make us healthier and happier? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
At the same time, though, emotional support animals have become a favorite butt of late-night TV jokes, conjuring images of people boarding planes with peacocks and hamsters in tow. So what does the research say about the effectiveness of animal-assisted therapy? When can animals help reduce distress and improve our mental health? health. What's the difference among service animals, therapy animals, and emotional support animals? What's backed by research and what is not? And what about regular household pets? How do our companion animals affect our health and well-being? Do our pets make us healthier and happier? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association|||然而与此同时，情感支持动物也成为了深夜电视节目笑话中最喜欢的笑柄，让人联想起人们带着孔雀和仓鼠登机的画面。那么，关于动物辅助治疗的效果，研究是怎么说的呢？动物在什么时候能够帮助减轻痛苦并改善我们的心理健康？健康状况。服务动物、治疗动物和情感 support 动物之间有什么区别？有哪些得到了研究支持，哪些没有？那么普通的家养宠物呢？我们的伴侣动物如何影响我们的健康和福祉？我们的宠物是否让我们更健康、更快乐？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客。
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Maggie O'Hare. Dr. O'Hare is a psychologist and an associate professor of animal-human interaction at the Purdue University College of Veterinary Medicine. Her research focuses on the ways that humans interact with animals, including both household pets and highly trained service animals. She runs National Institute of Health-funded studies on the effects of service dogs on veterans with post-traumatic stress disorder and on animal-assisted interventions for children with autism. She has published dozens of peer-reviewed publications and textbook chapters, and her work has been covered widely in the media, including the Wall Street Journal,
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Maggie O'Hare. Dr. O'Hare is a psychologist and an associate professor of animal-human interaction at the Purdue University College of Veterinary Medicine. Her research focuses on the ways that humans interact with animals, including both household pets and highly trained service animals. She runs National Institute of Health-funded studies on the effects of service dogs on veterans with post-traumatic stress disorder and on animal-assisted interventions for children with autism. She has published dozens of peer-reviewed publications and textbook chapters, and her work has been covered widely in the media, including the Wall Street Journal,|||该播客探讨了心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是玛吉·奥黑尔（Maggie O'Hare）博士。奥黑尔博士是普渡大学兽医学院的心理学家兼人与动物互动副教授。她的研究重点是人类与动物互动的方式，包括家养宠物和高度训练的服务犬。她负责由美国国立卫生研究院资助的研究，内容关于服务犬对患有创伤后应激障碍的退伍军人的影响，以及针对自闭症儿童的动物辅助干预措施。她发表了数十篇同行评审出版物和教科书章节，她的工作受到了媒体的广泛报道，包括《华尔街日报》、
the New York Times, and National Public Radio. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. O'Hare. Thank you so much for having me. It's my pleasure. Let's start by defining what we're talking about when we discuss the different types of animals that I mentioned in the introduction, service animals, emotional support animals, therapy dogs. These terms get thrown around, and I think mixed up by people who think they're interchangeable, but they're not. So can you tell us a little bit about what these terms mean and the differences among them? Absolutely, because I do agree. People get confused about this, and it's important at the start to figure out what we're talking about. And kind of if we take a step back, what we see is that the roles for dogs in our society
the New York Times, and National Public Radio. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. O'Hare. Thank you so much for having me. It's my pleasure. Let's start by defining what we're talking about when we discuss the different types of animals that I mentioned in the introduction, service animals, emotional support animals, therapy dogs. These terms get thrown around, and I think mixed up by people who think they're interchangeable, but they're not. So can you tell us a little bit about what these terms mean and the differences among them? Absolutely, because I do agree. People get confused about this, and it's important at the start to figure out what we're talking about. And kind of if we take a step back, what we see is that the roles for dogs in our society|||《纽约时报》和全国公共广播电台。非常感谢您今天加入我们，奥黑尔博士。非常感谢邀请我。这是我的荣幸。让我们首先来定义一下，当我们讨论我在引言中提到的不同类型的动物时，我们到底在指什么：服务动物、情感支持动物、治疗犬。这些术语经常被滥用，我认为人们常常把它们混淆，以为它们是可以互换的，但事实并非如此。所以，您能跟我们讲讲这些术语的含义以及它们之间的区别吗？当然可以，因为我非常赞同。人们对此感到困惑，因此在一开始弄清楚我们在谈论什么非常重要。如果我们退一步来看，我们会发现狗在我们社会中的角色
are increasing. And that's why we have these different niches of where dogs are helping. So the first category is a therapy dog. These are intended to provide comfort to individuals and different medical, residential, or academic settings. So if you think about, as an example, nursing homes where a dog might come in and visit, or hospitals where a dog might come and visit a child who is receiving treatments, these are someone's personal dogs that they volunteer as a therapy dog to bring in and provide comfort to many different individuals. The second category is an emotional support dog. These are medically prescribed for one specific individual to provide therapeutic benefits through dedicated companionship. So instead of visiting many people in many
are increasing. And that's why we have these different niches of where dogs are helping. So the first category is a therapy dog. These are intended to provide comfort to individuals and different medical, residential, or academic settings. So if you think about, as an example, nursing homes where a dog might come in and visit, or hospitals where a dog might come and visit a child who is receiving treatments, these are someone's personal dogs that they volunteer as a therapy dog to bring in and provide comfort to many different individuals. The second category is an emotional support dog. These are medically prescribed for one specific individual to provide therapeutic benefits through dedicated companionship. So instead of visiting many people in many|||正在增加。这就是为什么狗在不同的领域发挥着帮助作用。因此，第一类是治疗犬。这些犬旨在为个人以及不同的医疗、居住或学术环境提供安慰。例如，你可以想想疗养院，狗可能会去那里拜访；或者医院，狗可能会去探望正在接受治疗的儿童。这些都是某人的私家宠物，他们自愿将其作为治疗犬带入并为许多不同的人提供安慰。第二类是情感支持犬。这些是通过专门的陪伴为特定个人通过医疗处方提供的具有治疗益处的犬只。因此，它们不是去拜访许多人、在许多
settings, the emotional support dog stays with that one person. And then the final category, potentially of the highest level of rigor in training, is the service dog. And that is a dog that is trained to do a specific task to help mitigate a disability. And that's really what distinguishes that service dog from emotional support dog. The emotional support dog doesn't need to be trained to do a specific task and doesn't need to be with someone with a specific disability. Now, you're mentioning dogs specifically, but I think there are other animals that can be involved in some aspects of this type of work, right? Absolutely.
settings, the emotional support dog stays with that one person. And then the final category, potentially of the highest level of rigor in training, is the service dog. And that is a dog that is trained to do a specific task to help mitigate a disability. And that's really what distinguishes that service dog from emotional support dog. The emotional support dog doesn't need to be trained to do a specific task and doesn't need to be with someone with a specific disability. Now, you're mentioning dogs specifically, but I think there are other animals that can be involved in some aspects of this type of work, right? Absolutely.|||环境中，情感支持犬只会陪伴那一个人。然后是最后一类，其训练严谨度可能最高，那就是服务犬。这是一种经过训练可以执行特定任务以帮助减轻残疾的狗。这正是服务犬与情感支持犬的真正区别所在。情感支持犬不需要接受训练来执行特定任务，也不需要陪伴患有特定残疾的人。现在，你具体提到了狗，但我认为还有其他动物也可以参与这类工作的某些方面，对吧？绝对是的。
So if you're looking at a service animal, there are two species that can be service animals. Are you aware of what those two are? Do you know what the backup outside of a dog is? I don't. All right. Well, that's exciting that we can learn today. So the other species that can be a service animal is a miniature horse, actually. So that, you know, the logic behind that, there's a similar lifespan, a similar trainability,
So if you're looking at a service animal, there are two species that can be service animals. Are you aware of what those two are? Do you know what the backup outside of a dog is? I don't. All right. Well, that's exciting that we can learn today. So the other species that can be a service animal is a miniature horse, actually. So that, you know, the logic behind that, there's a similar lifespan, a similar trainability,|||所以如果你看服务动物，有两类物种可以成为服务动物。你知道那两类是什么吗？你知道除了狗之外的备选项是什么吗？我不知道。好的。太好了，今天我们可以学到新知识。所以实际上，另一种可以成为服务动物的物种是迷你马。你知道背后的逻辑是，它们有相似的寿命、相似的可训性，
similar size in some cases. And so although it is vastly less common, it is legally permissible to have a miniature horse as a service animal. Now, if you talk about emotional support animals, there are no species restrictions. So that does mean that technically anyone can have any species as their emotional support animal. Where there are some nuances are really airlines. So airlines used to say if you have an emotional support animal, they can come on the plane. Then they batten down the hatches a little bit and said only if they're specific species.
similar size in some cases. And so although it is vastly less common, it is legally permissible to have a miniature horse as a service animal. Now, if you talk about emotional support animals, there are no species restrictions. So that does mean that technically anyone can have any species as their emotional support animal. Where there are some nuances are really airlines. So airlines used to say if you have an emotional support animal, they can come on the plane. Then they batten down the hatches a little bit and said only if they're specific species.|||在某些情况下有相似的大小。因此，尽管这种情况要少得多，但在法律上允许将迷你马用作服务动物。现在，如果你谈论情感支持动物，则没有任何物种限制。这意味着从技术上讲，任何人都可以将任何物种作为他们的情感支持动物。有一些细微差别的地方其实是航空公司。因此，航空公司过去常常说，如果你有情感支持动物，它们就可以上飞机。然后他们收紧了政策，说只有特定物种才可以。
And now many airlines have moved further to only service animals that are allowed to travel with people on airlines. So where you are able to have that emotional support animal is really in your home of any species that you'd like. One of your main research projects is looking at the effects of service dogs on the mental health and wellness of military members diagnosed with PTSD and also their families. What have you found? How can service dogs help people with PTSD? What exactly does the dog do? We've been studying military veterans with PTSD and their families for the past six or seven years now. And so what we've been able to do thus far is really compare.
And now many airlines have moved further to only service animals that are allowed to travel with people on airlines. So where you are able to have that emotional support animal is really in your home of any species that you'd like. One of your main research projects is looking at the effects of service dogs on the mental health and wellness of military members diagnosed with PTSD and also their families. What have you found? How can service dogs help people with PTSD? What exactly does the dog do? We've been studying military veterans with PTSD and their families for the past six or seven years now. And so what we've been able to do thus far is really compare.|||现在许多航空公司进一步规定，只允许服务动物与人们一起在航空公司乘机旅行。因此，你能够养情感支持动物的地方实际上是在你的家中，可以是任何你喜欢的物种。你的主要研究项目之一是研究服务犬对被诊断患有创伤后应激障碍的军人及其家人的心理健康和福祉的影响。你们发现了什么？服务犬如何帮助患有创伤后应激障碍的人？狗具体做了什么？在过去的六七年里，我们一直在研究患有创伤后应激障碍的退伍军人及其家属。因此，到目前为止，我们能够做的是进行真正的比较。
cohorts of individuals who have a service dog to those who don't have a service dog. And what we find repeatedly in each study is that veterans with service dogs show clinically lower levels of PTSD symptomology than those who do not have a service dog. Now, obviously, it's limited to those individuals who are interested in a service dog who wanted that in the first place, but we do see that their symptoms are presenting at lower levels. We see that they have less absenteeism from work and an overall greater quality of life through their self-report. And when we dig deeper into that, what we find is that they have trained tasks that they're
cohorts of individuals who have a service dog to those who don't have a service dog. And what we find repeatedly in each study is that veterans with service dogs show clinically lower levels of PTSD symptomology than those who not have a service dog. Now, obviously, it's limited to those individuals who are interested in a service dog who wanted that in the first place, but we do see that their symptoms are presenting at lower levels. We see that they have less absenteeism from work and an overall greater quality of life through their self-report. And when we dig deeper into that, what we find is that they have trained tasks that they're|||拥有服务犬的个人群体与没有服务犬的个人群体。我们在每项研究中反复发现的是，拥有服务犬的退伍军人表现出的创伤后应激障碍症状在临床上低于没有服务犬的退伍军人。显而易见，这仅限于那些对服务犬感兴趣、一开始就想要服务犬的个人，但我们确实看到他们的症状呈现在较低的水平。我们发现通过他们的自我报告，他们的旷工率降低了，整体生活质量更高了。当我们深入研究这一点时，我们发现他们拥有训练有素的任务，即
using, right? Because as a service animal, it's there to help the disability. And by and large, the most common tasks they're using is to help address their anxiety symptoms. So on average, about three to five times a day, they'll use some sort of task or command to have the dog help them with their anxiety. So that might be asking the dog to lean up against them for deep pressure. That might be the dog noticing the individual's about to have a panic attack.
using, right? Because as a service animal, it's there to help the disability. And by and large, the most common tasks they're using is to help address their anxiety symptoms. So on average, about three to five times a day, they'll use some sort of task or command to have the dog help them with their anxiety. So that might be asking the dog to lean up against them for deep pressure. That might be the dog noticing the individual's about to have a panic attack.|||在使用的任务，对吧？因为作为服务动物，它的存在是为了帮助应对残疾。总的来说，他们使用的最常见的任务是帮助解决焦虑症状。因此，平均而言，他们每天会使用某种任务或口令大约三到五次，让狗来帮助他们缓解焦虑。所以这可能是要求狗靠在他们身上以提供深度压力。这可能是狗注意到这个人即将发生恐慌发作。
and nudging them to trigger them to come back to the present, take deep breaths and be mindful as a couple of examples of how the dogs are helping. So what we're trying to do is bring data behind these anecdotes that we hear. You know, so many veterans have said to us, I would not be alive if it were not for my service dog. And although, you know, that is emotionally salient for me and meaningful for many, what, you know, doctors, policymakers, insurance companies are looking for is the data behind that. And that's what we're hoping to pull together and what we've been able to do so far. One interesting point that you've made is that there are some potential drawbacks,
and nudging them to trigger them to come back to the present, take deep breaths and be mindful as a couple of examples of how the dogs are helping. So what we're trying to do is bring data behind these anecdotes that we hear. You know, so many veterans have said to us, I would not be alive if it were not for my service dog. And although, you know, that is emotionally salient for me and meaningful for many, what, you know, doctors, policymakers, insurance companies are looking for is the data behind that. And that's what we're hoping to pull together and what we've been able to do so far. One interesting point that you've made is that there are some potential drawbacks,|||并用鼻子轻推他们，以触发他们回到现实、深呼吸并保持正念，这是狗如何提供帮助的几个例子。因此，我们正在努力做的是为我们听到的这些轶事提供数据支持。你知道，许多退伍军人对我们说：“如果没有我的服务犬，我早就活不成了。”尽管这对我来说在情感上很突出，对许多人也很有意义，但你知道，医生、政策制定者、保险公司正在寻找的是这背后的数据。这正是我们希望汇集到一起的内容，也是我们迄今为止能够做到的事情。你提出的一个有趣的观点是，存在一些潜在的缺点，
including the fact that service dogs make visible what is essentially an invisible disability. Can you talk about that? Is that a concern for many of the veterans that you've worked with? You know, when we look at any form of animal-assisted intervention or service animal, any treatment, really, intervention, we want to ask, what is it doing well and what's an area where it can improve? And we were interested to find that for veterans, the biggest drawback or challenge, I suppose, that they do bring up is that, yes, when they're walking around in society without the dog, nobody notices them in the same way.
including the fact that service dogs make visible what is essentially an invisible disability. Can you talk about that? Is that a concern for many of the veterans that you've worked with? You know, when we look at any form of animal-assisted intervention or service animal, any treatment, really, intervention, we want to ask, what is it doing well and what's an area where it can improve? And we were interested to find that for veterans, the biggest drawback or challenge, I suppose, that they do bring up is that, yes, when they're walking around in society without the dog, nobody notices them in the same way.|||包括服务犬使原本本质上是无形的残疾变得显而易见这一事实。你能谈谈这个吗？这对于你合作过的许多退伍军人来说是一个担忧吗？你知道，当我们看任何形式的动物辅助干预或服务动物时，实际上是任何治疗、干预，我们都想问：它做得好的地方是什么？它可以改进的领域是什么？我们很有兴趣地发现，对于退伍军人来说，他们提出的最大的缺点或挑战（我想）是，是的，当他们在没有狗的情况下在社会中四处走动时，没有人会以同样的方式注意到他们。
But when they have their dog, people tend to love dogs and want to say hello and want to learn more. And so it draws attention to them. And for some veterans, they say, you know what, it's been good for me. It brings me out of my shell. I talk to people more. They show interest in me. And for other veterans, they say, I just want to go to the store and buy some milk. I don't want to be the subject of attention or interaction.
But when they have their dog, people tend to love dogs and want to say hello and want to learn more. And so it draws attention to them. And for some veterans, they say, you know what, it's been good for me. It brings me out of my shell. I talk to people more. They show interest in me. And for other veterans, they say, I just want to go to the store and buy some milk. I don't want to be the subject of attention or interaction.|||但是当他们带着狗时，人们往往喜欢狗，想要打招呼，想要了解更多。因此，这吸引了人们对他们的关注。对于一些退伍军人来说，他们说，你知道吗，这对我很好。它让我走出了封闭的内心。我跟人交谈更多了。他们对表现出兴趣。对于其他退伍军人，他们说，我只想去商店买点牛奶。我不想成为关注或互动的对象。
And I think that draws attention to the fact that we might need some more public education around this, around how to behave around people's service animals and how to be respectful. You've also studied animal-assisted interventions for kids with autism, including with service dogs, but also in some of your earlier work, with guinea pigs in classrooms. First of all, how did you end up with guinea pigs of all animals? And then what did you find in that research? How did these animals help kids with autism? Yes, well, thank you for asking about that.
And I think that draws attention to the fact that we might need some more public education around this, around how to behave around people's service animals and how to be respectful. You've also studied animal-assisted interventions for kids with autism, including with service dogs, but also in some of your earlier work, with guinea pigs in classrooms. First of all, how did you end up with guinea pigs of all animals? And then what did you find in that research? How did these animals help kids with autism? Yes, well, thank you for asking about that.|||我认为这引起了人们的注意，即我们可能需要围绕这一点开展更多的公众教育，了解如何在别人的服务动物周围表现以及如何保持尊重。你还研究过针对自闭症儿童的动物辅助干预，包括使用服务犬，但在你较早的一些工作中，还包括教室里的豚鼠。首先，在所有动物中，你最后怎么会选择豚鼠？然后在该研究中你发现了什么？这些动物是如何帮助自闭症儿童的？是的，很高兴你问到这个问题。
I think it's a fun story now at the time. It was actually, it came out of a few challenges that arose. So, you know, I did my bachelor's degree in psychology, and then I applied to do a full bright fellowship in Australia to study service dogs for autism. It was the perfect pairing. It was going to be it with a veterinarian and a psychologist. and the whole project would be so exciting. So I flew, I graduated with my degree in hand.
I think it's a fun story now at the time. It was actually, it came out of a few challenges that arose. So, you know, I did my bachelor's degree in psychology, and then I applied to do a full bright fellowship in Australia to study service dogs for autism. It was the perfect pairing. It was going to be it with a veterinarian and a psychologist. and the whole project would be so exciting. So I flew, I graduated with my degree in hand.|||我想现在回想起来这是一个有趣的故事。当时，这实际上是由出现的几个挑战引起的。所以，你知道，我获得了心理学学士学位，然后我申请去澳大利亚获得富布赖特奖学金，研究用于自闭症的服务犬。这是完美的搭配。它将由兽医和心理学家共同完成。整个项目将非常令人兴奋.所以我就飞去了，我手里拿着学位证书毕业了。
I flew to Australia. I arrived, slightly jet-lagged, and I went straight to the university to meet with my mentorship team for this project. And I was informed, well, the psychologist has quit. And we don't have any funding for the project. And so welcome. Go home. Well, that's exactly, Kim, what I questioned myself in that moment. you know, I finished the meeting and I had this long walk home.
I flew to Australia. I arrived, slightly jet-lagged, and I went straight to the university to meet with my mentorship team for this project. And I was informed, well, the psychologist has quit. And we don't have any funding for the project. And so welcome. Go home. Well, that's exactly, Kim, what I questioned myself in that moment. you know, I finished the meeting and I had this long walk home.|||我飞往澳大利亚。我到达时有点时差，然后我直接去了大学，与这个项目的导师团队会面。我被告知，好吧，心理学家已经辞职了。而且我们没有任何该项目的资金。所以，欢迎。回家吧。嗯，金，这正是我当时对自己的质问。你知道，我开完会后，走了很长一段路回家。
It was a long walk because I wasn't exactly sure where I was going. It was foreign territory a good time to think. And, you know, I reflected and I thought, do I turn around? Do I go home? Is this a message that this isn't going to happen? And on that walk, I really thought to myself, no, I want to study this. So what I did is first I learned to apply for a grant. I didn't know what that word meant before, but I did that.
It was a long walk because I wasn't exactly sure where I was going. It was foreign territory a good time to think. And, you5 know, I reflected and I thought, do I turn around? Do I go home? Is this a message that this isn't going to happen? And on that walk, I really thought to myself, no, I want to study this. So what I did is first I learned to apply for a grant. I didn't know what that word meant before, but I did that.|||这是一段漫长的路，因为我不太确定我要去哪里。这是个陌生的领域，是一个思考的好时机。你知道，我反思并想过，我要转身吗？我要回家吗？这是一个信号，表明这件事不会发生吗？在那次步行中，我真的对自己说，不，我想研究这个。所以我做的第一件事是学会申请资助。我以前不知道那个词是什么意思，但我做到了。
And second, I had to find another source of ANO. You know, service dogs are expensive. I had no funding. So what I found out was that the local vet school was doing research on guinea pigs. And the type of research they did is they were breeding the animals and then after day two of the guinea pigs' life, they didn't need them. So they would either euthanize the animal or give them to me for free. And so that was a very convenient and cost-effective model. I socialized the guinea pigs from that young age and developed a classroom-based intervention program. And what I actually learned is that the guinea pigs were at quite a scalable intervention,
And second, I had to find another source of ANO. You know, service dogs are expensive. I had no funding. So what I found out was that the local vet school was doing research on guinea pigs. And the type of research they did is they were breeding the animals and then after day two of the guinea pigs' life, they didn't need them. So they would either euthanize the animal or give them to me for free. And so that was a very convenient and cost-effective model. I socialized the guinea pigs from that young age and developed a classroom-based intervention program. And what I actually learned is that the guinea pigs were at quite a scalable intervention,|||第二，我必须找到另一个动物（ANO，原文误拼）来源。你知道，服务犬很贵。我没有资金。所以我发现当地的兽医学校正在对豚鼠进行研究。他们进行的研究类型是他们繁殖动物，然后在豚鼠出生后的第二天之后，他们不再需要它们。所以他们要么对动物实施安乐死，要么免费给我。所以这是一个非常方便且具有成本效益的模式。我从很小的时候就开始对豚鼠进行社会化训练，并开发了一个基于教室的干预项目。我真正学到的是，豚鼠是一个相当可扩展的干预措施，
you know? Not every classroom has the capacity to afford and care for a dog in it. But with the guinea pigs, we could have a housing enclosure in the classroom that was consistent and stable. And what we found is that for many of the kids having that there at all times, when they felt stressed, they could go sit next to the cage and watch the animals. And what we also found was that although for many adults, a dog seems more exciting than a guinea pig. For these children, they were so excited about these little creatures that they
you know? Not every classroom has the capacity to afford and care for a dog in it. But with the guinea pigs, we could have a housing enclosure in the classroom that was consistent and stable. And what we found is that for many of the kids having that there at all times, when they felt stressed, they could go sit next to the cage and watch the animals. And what we also found was that although for many adults, a dog seems more exciting than a guinea pig. For these children, they were so excited about these little creatures that they|||你知道吗？并不是每个教室都有能力负担并在其中照顾一只狗。但有了豚鼠，我们可以在教室里有一个一致且稳定的饲养围栏。我们发现，对于许多随时都能接触到这些动物的孩子来说，当他们感到压力时，他们可以走到笼子旁边坐着看动物。我们还发现，尽管对于许多成年人来说，狗似乎比豚鼠更令人兴奋。对于这些孩子来说，他们对这些小生物感到非常兴奋，以至于他们
were going to learn to care for and nurture. And honestly, it turned out to be a blessing in disguise. Well, how did the children improve? I mean, were they more socialized than to deal with other children, or was it just because they, you know, related to the animals? We found many different things from this program. So we were looking at children with autism spectrum disorder in mainstream or inclusion classrooms. So we studied not only the child with autism, but also some of their typically developing peers. And what we found is that the children with autism were able to integrate more with their peers
were going to learn to care for and nurture. And honestly, it turned out to be a blessing in disguise. Well, how did the children improve? I mean, were they more socialized than to deal with other children, or was it just because they, you know, related to the animals? We found many different things from this program. So we were looking at children with autism spectrum disorder in mainstream or inclusion classrooms. So we studied not only the child with autism, but also some of their typically developing peers. And what we found is that the children with autism were able to integrate more with their peers|||将学习照顾和培育它们。说实话，这最终成了塞翁失马，焉知非福。嗯，孩子们的改善体现在哪里？我的意思是，与其他人际交往相比，他们是否更具社交性，还是仅仅因为他们，你知道的，与动物产生了共鸣？我们从这个项目中发现了许多不同的事情。因此，我们研究了主流或融合教室中的自闭症谱系障碍儿童。所以我们不仅研究了自闭症儿童，还研究了他们的一些典型发育同龄人。我们发现自闭症儿童能够更好地与同龄人融为一体
when the animal was present. They were talking more with their peers. They were looking at their peers more. They were smiling, laughing, and engaging more. And we used a comparison condition of toys. So we compared the guinea pigs to toys. And as you know, you know, toys are designed built. sold to elicit engagement from children. And so the fact that a guinea pig, who's not doing
when the animal was present. They were talking more with their peers. They were looking at their peers more. They were smiling, laughing, and engaging more. And we used a comparison condition of toys. So we compared the guinea pigs to toys. And as you know, you know, toys are designed built. sold to elicit engagement from children. And so the fact that a guinea pig, who's not doing|||当动物在场时。他们与同龄人交流更多。他们更多地看着他们的同龄人。他们微笑、大笑并更多地参与。我们使用了玩具的对照条件。所以我们将豚鼠与玩具进行了比较。如你所知，你知道，玩具的设计建造是为了引起儿童的参与。因此，事实是，一只并没有做什么特别的豚鼠，
anything particularly special, could elicit more social behaviors was fascinating to us as we commenced in this field. And that was in the moment behavioral changes. But we also saw, you know, broader changes over time. Teachers and parents were reporting more social engagement, more social skills and less challenging behaviors in the classroom as well. Let's switch gears for a minute and talk about household pets. It's probably obvious. to a lot of people that pets make us happy, but is the research that supports the idea that pets are good for our physical and mental health? What does the data say? What does the data say? That is what I eat, sleep and breathe in my role. So I'm glad that you ask. And it's interesting
anything particularly special, could elicit more social behaviors was fascinating to us as we commenced in this field. And that was in the moment behavioral changes. But we also saw, you know, broader changes over time. Teachers and parents were reporting more social engagement, more social skills and less challenging behaviors in the classroom as well. Let's switch gears for a minute and talk about household pets. It's probably obvious. to a lot of people that pets make us happy, but is the research that supports the idea that pets are good for our physical and mental health? What does the data say? What does the data say? That is what I eat, sleep and breathe in my role. So I'm glad that you ask. And it's interesting|||特别的豚鼠，却能引发更多的社会行为，这在我们刚进入这个领域时让我们着迷。那是当下的行为改变。但随着时间的推移，我们也看到了更广泛的变化。老师和家长们也报告说，课堂上有更多的社会参与、更多的社交技能以及更少具有挑战性的行为。让我们换个话题，谈谈家养宠物。对于许多人来说，宠物能让我们快乐这可能是显而易见的，但是有没有支持“宠物对我们的身心健康有益”这一观点的研究呢？数据是怎么说的？数据是怎么说的？这就是我职责范围内日思夜想的事情。所以我很高兴你问这个问题。这很有趣
because I think that many people or potentially pet owners or pet lovers will say, it's obvious. We already know this. Why would we study it? But in actuality, you know, in some of the top psychology journals, people have questioned that and said, is this a mere hypothesis rather than a supported fact empirically? And I think one of the challenges comes from the way we study it, right? It's a lot of it is correlational in nature, meaning that we don't know if the animal caused improved mental health or people with higher mental health to begin with go out to adopt or purchase an animal. So we're trying to tease that apart through different studies. And some of the best ways we can do that is look at when you're with the animal versus not. And we do find that when you're with the animal,
because I think that many people or potentially pet owners or pet lovers will say, it's obvious. We already know this. Why would we study it? But in actuality, you know, in some of the top psychology journals, people have questioned that and said, is this a mere hypothesis rather than a supported fact empirically? And I think one of the challenges comes from the way we study it, right? It's a lot of it is correlational in nature, meaning that we don't know if the animal caused improved mental health or people with higher mental health to begin with go out to adopt or purchase an animal. So we're trying to tease that apart through different studies. And some of the best ways we can do that is look at when you're with the animal versus not. And we do find that when you're with the animal,|||因为我认为许多人或潜在的宠物主人或宠物爱好者会说：“这显而易见。我们已经知道了。为什么还要研究它？”但实际上，你知道，在一些顶级心理学期刊中，人们对此提出过质疑，并表示这是否只是一种假设，而不是经验上得到证实的事实？我认为挑战之一来自于我们研究它的方式，对吧？它在本质上很大程度上是相关的，这意味着我们不知道是动物改善了心理健康，还是原本心理健康水平较高的人走出去领养或购买了动物。因此，我们正试图通过不同的研究来厘清这一点。我们可以做到这一点的最好方法之一就是观察你和动物在一起时与不在一起时的对比。我们确实发现，当你和动物在一起时，
you smile and talk to people more. You show changes in your physiology, whether that be increases in oxytocin or what's called the love hormone or reductions in your anxious arousals, such as heart rate or blood pressure. We are able to see these momentary changes. And I think where the field is moving is to find out whether these are related to long-term lasting or broader gains. And it's just been challenging because it's harder to randomize someone to get a dog versus not get a dog. You know, humans are autonomous. And when they want to get a dog, they're going to go ahead and get it regardless of whether you want to assign that to them in the study. So I think we also gain a lot of knowledge from our service and therapy animal studies, although it is different.
you smile and talk to people more. You show changes in your physiology, whether that be increases in oxytocin or what's called the love hormone or reductions in your anxious arousals, such as heart rate or blood pressure. We are able to see these momentary changes. And I think where the field is moving is to find out whether these are related to long-term lasting or broader gains. And it's just been challenging because it's harder to randomize someone to get a dog versus not get a dog. You know, humans are autonomous. And when they want to get a dog, they're going to go ahead and get it regardless of whether you want to assign that to them in the study. So I think we also gain a lot of knowledge from our service and therapy animal studies, although it is different.|||你会微笑并更多地与人交谈。你会表现出生理上的变化，无论是催产素（被称为爱情荷尔蒙）的增加，还是焦虑唤醒水平的降低（例如心率或血压）。我们能够看到这些短暂的变化。我认为该领域正在发展的方向是弄清楚这些变化是否与长期持久或更广泛的收益有关。这一直很有挑战性，因为很难随机分配某人养狗与不养狗。你知道，人类是自主的。当他们想要养狗时，无论你是否想在研究中将这分配给他们，他们都会继续去养。因此，我认为我们从服务动物和治疗动物研究中也获得了许多知识，尽管它有所不同。
Those are groups where we can randomize and we can have that built-in waiting period to try and extrapolate some of the changes we see there to pet ownership. I think we need to take that with some caveats, though, because a service animal is often bred and trained and prepared specifically to be wonderful for the human and to behave, you know, in specific ways, whereas our companion animals aren't always behaving or performing at that level. So I think that one of the key things that I like to talk with new or potential companion animal owners about is managing those expectations. You know, I think there's this dichotomy that we see. You know, some people say this pets are good for everything and they're amazing and some people talk just about the challenges. And I think ultimately it's a
Those are groups where we can randomize and we can have that built-in waiting period to try and extrapolate some of the changes we see there to pet ownership. I think we need to take that with some caveats, though, because a service animal is often bred and trained and prepared specifically to be wonderful for the human and to behave, you know, in specific ways, whereas our companion animals aren't always behaving or performing at that level. So I think that one of the key things that I like to talk with new or potential companion animal owners about is managing those expectations. You know, I think there's this dichotomy that we see. You know, some people say this pets are good for everything and they're amazing and some people talk just about the challenges. And I think ultimately it's a|||这些是我们可以进行随机分组的群体，并且我们可以设置内置的等待期，试图将我们在那里看到的一些变化推断到宠物主人身上。不过，我认为我们需要对此持一些保留态度，因为服务动物通常是专门培育、训练和准备的，对人类非常友好，并且表现出特定方式的行为，你知道的，而我们的伴侣动物并不总是表现或达到那个水平。因此，我喜欢与新的或潜在的伴侣动物主人谈论的关键事情之一就是管理这些期望。你知道，我认为我们看到了这种二分法。你知道，有些人说这些宠物万能而且太棒了，有些人只谈论挑战。我认为最终这是一个
balance. And I think if owners can go in knowing, hey, the initial phases, there'll be some growing pains. You'll have to learn about each other. If you have a puppy or a small animal, there's going to be potty training. But if you can build that bond and move through those initial tough phases, that's when you'll start to see some of those broader, longer term gains when you develop that rich and intimate bond with the other creature. Are there differences among the kinds of animals that we have as pets? Is there something, you know, you always feel like, well, if you can hold the animal, if it's tactile, then that, you know, is going to, you'll feel that in a more gut, on a gut level, as opposed to having goldfish, or even if you have a, you know, a tiny pet like a mouse or a rat,
balance. And I think if owners can go in knowing, hey, the initial phases, there'll be some growing pains. You'll have to learn about each other. If you have a puppy or a small animal, there's going to be potty training. But if you can build that bond and move through those initial tough phases, that's when you'll start to see some of those broader, longer term gains when you develop that rich and intimate bond with the other creature. Are there differences among the kinds of animals that we have as pets? Is there something, you know, you always feel like, well, if you can hold the animal, if it's tactile, then that, you know, is going to, you'll feel that in a more gut, on a gut level, as opposed to having goldfish, or even if you have a, you know, a tiny pet like a mouse or a rat,|||平衡。我认为，如果主人能够带着这样的认知进入其中：嘿，最初的阶段会有一些成长痛。你们必须相互了解。如果你有一只小狗或小动物，就会有如厕训练。但是，如果你能建立这种联系并度过最初的艰难阶段，当你与另一个生物建立起丰富而亲密的联系时，你就会开始看到一些更广泛、更长期的收益。我们作为宠物的动物种类之间有什么区别吗？有什么东西，你知道的，你总是觉得，好吧，如果你能抱住动物，如果它是触觉的，那么，你知道的，你会从更直观的、肠胃的层面上感受到这一点，而不是养金鱼，甚至如果你有一只，你知道的，像老鼠或大鼠这样的小宠物，
where you can't, you know, you can't really hug it because you're going to hurt it. Does that make a difference in the way that people react or they healthier or happier with certain kinds of animals as compared to others? I think there are absolutely species differences, and I think you tapped into a really key element of that, and that's that physical tactile element. But I think it's not necessarily that one's better than the other, but it's different. So if you think about potentially fish tanks, we've had some really interesting studies that show how your heart rate and your blood pressure are lowered when you're looking at the
where you can't, you know, you can't really hug it because you're going to hurt it. Does that make a difference in the way that people react or they healthier or happier with certain kinds of animals as compared to others? I think there are absolutely species differences, and I think you tapped into a really key element of that, and that's that physical tactile element. But I think it's not necessarily that one's better than the other, but it's different. So if you think about potentially fish tanks, we've had some really interesting studies that show how your heart rate and your blood pressure are lowered when you're looking at the|||你不能，你知道的，你不能真正拥抱它，因为你会伤害它。这会改变人们的反应方式吗，或者与养其他种类的动物相比，养某些种类的动物的人是否更健康或更快乐？我认为绝对存在物种差异，而且我认为你切中了其中的一个真正关键的要素，那就是身体触觉要素。但我认为这不一定是哪个比另一个更好，而是它们有所不同。因此，如果你考虑潜在的鱼缸，我们进行了一些非常有趣的研究，表明当你看着
fish tank. And so following studies like that, I mean, you're hard pressed to find a doctor's officer waiting room that doesn't have a fish tank because after those studies came out, people realize that if it's going to reduce your anxious arousal, we want to have that in places that are going to become stressful to center your attention. So we have this theory. It's called the biophilia hypothesis. And it's been around for decades. And it's the idea that as humans evolutionarily were primed to look at animals in nature. And we have this, you know, unconscious bias to attend to that. And when we have that external positive focus of attention, it can reduce our anxiety and our arousal. And so that's, you know, the species that we can't
fish tank. And so following studies like that, I mean, you're hard pressed to find a doctor's officer waiting room that doesn't have a fish tank because after those studies came out, people realize that if it's going to reduce your anxious arousal, we want to have that in places that are going to become stressful to center your attention. So we have this theory. It's called the biophilia hypothesis. And it's been around for decades. And it's the idea that as humans evolutionarily were primed to look at animals in nature. And we have this, you know, unconscious bias to attend to that. And when we have that external positive focus of attention, it can reduce our anxiety and our arousal. And so that's, you5 know, the species that we can't|||鱼缸时，你的心率和血压会降低。因此，在进行此类研究之后，我的意思是，你很难找到一个没有鱼缸的医生办公室候诊室，因为这些研究出来后，人们意识到如果它能减少你的焦虑唤醒，我们希望将其放在会变得有压力的地方，以集中你的注意力。所以我们有这个理论。它被称为生物亲和假说（biophilia hypothesis）。它已经存在了几十年。这个观点是，作为人类，在进化上我们天生就会关注自然界中的动物。我们有一种，你知道的，无意识的偏好去关注这一点。当我们拥有那种外部的积极注意力焦点时，它可以减少我们的焦虑和唤醒。所以这就是，你知道的，我们无法
interact with physically, those things happen. Even when it's an animal that we typically would like to pet or interact with physically, if we just watch a video of those animals, we will see similar outcomes. So I think you're gathering those benefits. And then when you do move into the place where you're able to physically interact with the animal, I think there's several different things that can happen. I think that that soft contact touch has been related to reductions in anxiety and arousal and also to increases in some of our bonding and social neuroscience love hormones such as oxytocin. So we're triggering those other elements. And I think that over time, if we look at social relationships and bonding, probably the touch piece is important in developing that over time.
interact with physically, those things happen. Even when it's an animal that we typically would like to pet or interact with physically, if we just watch a video of those animals, we will see similar outcomes. So I think you're gathering those benefits. And then when you do move into the place where you're able to physically interact with the animal, I think there's several different things that can happen. I think that that soft contact touch has been related to reductions in anxiety and arousal and also to increases in some of our bonding and social neuroscience love hormones such as oxytocin. So we're triggering those other elements. And I think that over time, if we look at social relationships and bonding, probably the touch piece is important in developing that over time.|||进行身体互动的物种，这些事情也会发生。即使是一只我们通常喜欢抚摸或进行身体互动的动物，如果我们只观看这些动物的视频，我们也会看到类似的结果。所以我认为你正在收集这些好处。然后当你真正进入能够与动物进行身体互动的地方时，我认为可能会发生几件不同的事情。我认为这种柔软的接触与焦虑和唤醒的减少有关，也与我们的一些依恋和社交神经科学爱情荷尔蒙（如催产素）的增加有关。所以我们正在触发其他这些要素。我认为随着时间的推移，如果我们着眼于社会关系和依恋，随着时间的推移，触摸部分在发展这种关系方面可能很重要。
Though you might talk to a reptile or fish owner that argues quite differently. You know, I have certainly met people who talk so fondly about the bond they've developed with other creatures, but I would say on the whole, yes, that contact does play a key role in the bonding element. I think somewhere in that answer, I heard you say something that explains why we love to watch cat videos. You know, that is a big one. Whenever I am lecturing about how we have this affinity to look at life and life-like creatures, I do show elements of cat videos.
Though you might talk to a reptile or fish owner that argues quite differently. You know, I have certainly met people who talk so fondly about the bond they've developed with other creatures, but I would say on the whole, yes, that contact does play a key role in the bonding element. I think somewhere in that answer, I heard you say something that explains why we love to watch cat videos. You know, that is a big one. Whenever I am lecturing about how we have this affinity to look at life and life-like creatures, I do show elements of cat videos.|||尽管你可能会与爬行动物或鱼类的主人交谈，他们的观点大不相同。你知道，我确实遇到过这样的人，他们深情地谈论他们与其他生物之间建立的联系，但我总的来说会说，是的，这种接触确实在联系要素中起着关键作用。我想在那回答的某个地方，我听到你说了一些解释为什么我们喜欢看猫视频的话。你知道，这是一个很大的话题。每当我讲授我们如何对观察生命和类生命生物有这种亲和力时，我都会展示猫视频的元素。
You know, there's something called the Internet Cat Video Festival that's been going on for many years now, which I myself have not attended. But it's from what I understand people watching videos of cats together. And there have been studies looking at, you know, when you watch cute animal videos, how that affects your level of attention and your mood. And it does seem like when we have absence of the real thing, watching a video does a pretty good job. So let's talk a little bit about emotional support animals. We had years of these viral news stories about people bringing peacocks and kangaroos onto airplanes. And then in December, TSA announced that airlines would no longer be required to accommodate emotional support animals, only trained service animals, as you said earlier. Is there research out there on whether these emotional support animals actually do help people cope with mental illness and emotional distress?
You know, there's something called the Internet Cat Video Festival that's been going on for many years now, which I myself have not attended. But it's from what I understand people watching videos of cats together. And there have been studies looking at, you know, when you watch cute animal videos, how that affects your level of attention and your mood. And it does seem like when we have absence of the real thing, watching a video does a pretty good job. So let's talk a little bit about emotional support animals. We had years of these viral news stories about people bringing peacocks and kangaroos onto airplanes. And then in December, TSA announced that airlines would no longer be required to accommodate emotional support animals, only trained service animals, as you said earlier. Is there research out there on whether these emotional support animals actually do help people cope with mental illness and emotional distress?|||你知道，有一个名为“互联网猫视频节”的活动已经举办了很多年，我自己没有参加过。但据我了解，人们是在一起观看猫的视频。并且有研究在观察，你知道，当你观看可爱的动物视频时，这如何影响你的注意力和你的情绪。看起来，当我们缺少真实的东西时，观看视频做得相当不错。那么我们来谈谈情感支持动物。我们有多年的这些病毒式新闻报道，关于人们把孔雀和袋鼠带上飞机。然后在 12 月，运输安全管理局（TSA）宣布，航空公司将不再被要求容纳情感支持动物，正如你之前所说，只允许训练有素的服务动物。是否有关于这些情感支持动物是否真的能帮助人们应对精神疾病和情感困扰的研究？
Is this really a valid therapeutic treatment? I think this is a growing area where we need more research. But what I will say is that if you think about a companion animal versus an emotional support animal, I mean, what companion animal isn't potentially providing emotional support? So I do think that we can draw on the literature we have about companion animals for broader impacts. And we can see that there are benefits that could be gained. But I don't think we have much research yet that's really digging into it. emotional support animals specifically. We've really started with companion animals and service
Is this really a valid therapeutic treatment? I think this is a growing area where we need more research. What I will say is that if you think about a companion animal versus an emotional support animal, I mean, what companion animal isn't potentially providing emotional support? So I do think that we can draw on the literature we have about companion animals for broader impacts. And we can see that there are benefits that could be gained. But I don't think we have much research yet that's really digging into it. emotional support animals specifically. We've really started with companion animals and service|||这真的是一种有效的治疗方法吗？我认为这是一个不断增长的领域，我们需要更多的研究。我要说的是，如果你把伴侣动物与情感支持动物进行比较，我的意思是，哪种伴侣动物不是在潜在地提供情感支持呢？所以我确实认为我们可以借鉴我们关于伴侣动物的文献来了解更广泛的影响。我们可以看到可以获得的收益。但我认为我们还没有多少真正深入研究它的研究。特别是情感支持动物。我们实际上是从伴侣动物和服务动物开始的
animals. And I think emotional support animals will be our next big area to look into. So let's talk about your career for a moment. You have a very unusual situation where you work in a veterinary school as a psychologist. My understanding is that you are one of one or two people who are in this position right now. And how is it different for a psychologist working in a veterinary school as opposed to being just in a psychology department someplace. It's a lot of fun. So, you know, I've been in psychology department and I've been in the College of Veterinary Medicine and you are correct. There's only, you know, one other tenure track psychologist in a College of Veterinary Medicine that I'm aware of at the moment. And I would say the main difference in working in the
animals. And I think emotional support animals will be our next big area to look into. So let's talk for a moment about your career. You have a very unusual situation where you work in a veterinary school as a psychologist. My understanding is that you are one of one or two people who are in this position right now. And how is it different for a psychologist working in a veterinary school as opposed to being just in a psychology department someplace. It's a lot of fun. So, you know, I've been in psychology department and I've been in the College of Veterinary Medicine and you are correct. There's only, you know, one other tenure track psychologist in a College of Veterinary Medicine that I'm aware of at the moment. And I would say the main difference in working in the|||动物。我认为情感支持动物将是我们接下来要深入研究的大领域。因此，我们来谈谈你的职业生涯。你有一个非常不寻常的情况，即你在兽医学校担任心理学家。据我所知，你是目前处于这个职位的仅有的少数人之一。心理学家在兽医学校工作与仅仅在某个地方的心理学系工作有什么不同？这非常有趣。所以，你知道，我在心理学系待过，我也在兽医学院待过，你是对的。据我目前所知，在兽医学院里，只有另外一位拥有终身教职追踪（tenure track）的心理学家。我要说的是，在
vet school versus psychology department is whether or not you have to defend what you do all day. So I think that in, you know, traditional streams of psychology, this isn't something that comes up in Psych 101. It doesn't come up in your training. And so it is kind of a more niche field. And when I was in psychology, I had to defend why it was a rigorous field of study. In the vet school, no one asks me questions. They accept and acknowledge and know how important it is because they see it every single day. So I have to say, for me, it was so fun to be, you know, invited to do this podcast because
vet school versus psychology department is whether or not you have to defend what you do all day. So I think that in, you know, traditional streams of psychology, this isn't something that comes up in Psych 101. It doesn't come up in your training. And so it is kind of a more niche field. And when I was in psychology, I had to defend why it was a rigorous field of study. In the vet school, no one asks me questions. They accept and acknowledge and know how important it is because they see it every single day. So I have to say, for me, it was so fun to be, you know, invited to do this podcast because|||兽医学校与在心理学系工作的主要区别在于，你是否必须为自己整天所做的事情进行辩护。所以我认为在，你知道的，心理学的传统流派中，这不是心理学 101（Psych 101）中会出现的事情。它不会出现在你的培训中。所以这有点像一个更小众的领域。当我在心理学界时，我必须为为什么这是一个严谨的研究领域进行辩护。在兽医学校，没有人问我问题。他们接受、承认并知道它是多么重要，因为他们每天都看到它。所以我必须说，对我来说，能够被邀请参加这个播客是非常有趣的，因为
my background, my trainings in psychology, I think it's the field where we should be studying this. And I don't think it has always been accepted as much as it has been in recent years. And I think a lot of that has to do with, you know, once the National Institutes of Health started funding this, people took it a bit more seriously. And now I also think that clinicians are seeing so many requests for a service animal, a therapy animal, animal assisted intervention. And they are looking for data to answer those questions. And so I'm so excited to be a able to share that data and inform our field. How did you get interested in studying human-animal interaction? Was this something that you were always interested in, or did you start in a more typical
my background, my trainings in psychology, I think it's the field where we should be studying this. And I don't think it has always been accepted as much as it has been in recent years. And I think a lot of that has to do with, you know, once the National Institutes of Health started funding this, people took it a bit more seriously. And now I also think that clinicians are seeing so many requests for a service animal, a therapy animal, animal assisted intervention. And they are looking for data to answer those questions. And so I'm so excited to be a able to share that data and inform our field. How did you get interested in studying human-animal interaction? Was this something that you were always interested in, or did you start in a more typical|||我的背景、我的心理学培训，我认为这是我们应该研究这个领域的领域。我不认为它一直像近年来那样被广泛接受。我认为这在很大程度上与，你知道的，一旦美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）开始资助这个项目，人们就会更加认真地对待它有关。现在我也认为临床医生看到了对服务动物、治疗动物、动物辅助干预的大量请求。他们正在寻找数据来回答这些问题。所以我非常高兴能分享这些数据并为我们的领域提供信息。你是如何对研究人与动物互动产生兴趣的？这是你一直感兴趣的事情，还是你从更典型的
human-only psychology program? I absolutely started in the typical way in a human-only psychology program, and it was actually during my undergrad degree, you know, in psych classes, they will let you choose your own topic. And naively, I thought I was inventing my own topic when I I decided to think about the impact of animals on children's empathy. As I started to look into it, I found it's actually a field where people are studying it. And I went to college at Vassar College in New York. And there was a place just 45 minutes away called the Green Chimney School, which is a world leader in providing therapy animals in a school residential setting. So what I did is I reached out to Green Chimneys and I said, hey, what research are you doing?
human-only psychology program? I absolutely started in the typical way in a human-only psychology program, and it was actually during my undergrad degree, you know, in psych classes, they will let you choose your own topic. And naively, I thought I was inventing my own topic when I I decided to think about the impact of animals on children's empathy. As I started to look into it, I found it's actually a field where people are studying it. And I went to college at Vassar College in New York. And there was a place just 45 minutes away called the Green Chimney School, which is a world leader in providing therapy animals in a school residential setting. So what I did is I reached out to Green Chimneys and I said, hey, what research are you doing?|||纯人类心理学项目开始的？我绝对是以典型的方式从一个纯人类心理学项目开始的，实际上是在我读本科期间，你知道的，在心理学课上，他们会让你选择自己的主题。天真地，当我决定思考动物对儿童同理心的影响时，我以为我是在发明自己的主题。当我开始深入研究它时，我发现这实际上是一个人们正在研究的领域。我在纽约的瓦萨学院（Vassar College）上大学。距离那里仅 45 分钟车程有一个叫绿烟囱学校（Green Chimney School）的地方，它是提供学校宿舍环境治疗动物的世界领导者。所以我做的是联系绿烟囱学校，我说：“嘿，你们在做什么研究？”
Can I do an internship? Can I help you out? And they said, hi, we do not accept interns that we don't have a program. We're not doing that much research. Thank you. Goodbye. And for better or for worse, based on my personality, I persisted and said, you know, I have some ideas. I think I could come in once a week and help you, you know, set up informed consent and conduct research and really track these outcomes. And their clinical department was amazing and took me on and let me start this journey with them. And that one thing led to another, and I realized that I could keep pushing it. What I will say is that all along the way, I was advised not to make this my career. I was definitely advised to pick something mainstream. You have to have, you know, you need it to be developmental. You need it to be social. You need it to be something that's in our career lines that we're used to seeing. and I decided to ignore that advice and continue to pursue my passion.
Can I do an internship? Can I help you out? And they said, hi, we do not accept interns that we don't have a program. We're not doing that much research. Thank you. Goodbye. And for better or for worse, based on my personality, I persisted and said, you know, I have some ideas. I think I could come in once a week and help you, you know, set up informed consent and conduct research and really track these outcomes. And their clinical department was amazing and took me on and let me start this journey with them. And that one thing led to another, and I realized that I could keep pushing it. What I will say is that all along the way, I was advised not to make this my career. I was definitely advised to pick something mainstream. You have to have, you know, you need it to be developmental. You need it to be social. You need it to be something that's in our career lines that we're used to seeing. and I decided to ignore that advice and continue to pursue my passion.|||“我可以实习吗？我能帮上忙吗？”他们说：“嗨，我们不接受没有项目的实习生。我们没有做那么多研究。谢谢。再见。”不管好坏，根据我的性格，我坚持了下来，并说：“你知道，我有一些想法。我想我每周可以来一次，帮助你们，你知道，建立知情同意书，进行研究并真正追踪这些结果。”他们的临床部门太棒了，接受了我，并让我与他们开始了这段旅程。事情就这样一件接一件地发生了，我意识到我可以继续推进它。我要说的是，一路走来，有人建议我不要把这作为我的职业。我绝对被建议选择一些主流的东西。你必须拥有，你知道的，你需要它是发展的。你需要它是社会的。你需要它是我们习惯在职业道路上看到的东西。我决定忽略这个建议，继续追求我的热情。
And I feel very fortunate that it worked out and that I can now run my own lab and study this and spend my days, you know, digging into the psychology behind why we interact with animals, how it impacts our mental health and wellness. And I'm heartened to see that I think there are a growing number of careers in this area. I'm not sure that everyone should ignore the advice to have a mainstream path to fall back on. But I think that, you know, adding this into your portfolio is a growing trend. Did Purdue create this slot and you applied for it? Or did you go to them and tell them that they need somebody like you in their veterinary school?
And I feel very fortunate that it worked out and that I can now run my own lab and study this and spend my days, you know, digging into the psychology behind why we interact with animals, how it impacts our mental health and wellness. And I'm heartened to see that I think there are a growing number of careers in this area. I'm not sure that everyone should ignore the advice to have a mainstream path to fall back on. But I think that, you know, adding this into your portfolio is a growing trend. Did Purdue create this slot and you applied for it? Or did you go to them and tell them that they need somebody like you in their veterinary school?|||我感到非常幸运，事情成功了，我现在可以经营自己的实验室并研究这个，把我的日子花在，你知道的，钻研为什么我们与动物互动背后的心理学，它如何影响我们的心理健康和福祉。我很高兴地看到，我认为这个领域的职业生涯正在不断增加。我不确定每个人都应该忽略拥有主流退路路线的建议。但我认为，你知道的，将这一点加入到你的作品集中是一个不断发展的趋势。是普渡大学设立了这个职位然后你申请了吗？还是你去找他们并告诉他们他们的兽医学校需要像你这样的人？
How did that happen? So my first NIH grant that I got, I was in Australia and partnered with Purdue University because they were in the U.S. And it was easier to, you know, fund something from the U.S. government in the U.S. And I formed a partnership with Purdue through that grant. And when they opened up a new position, they called me and said, you know, we don't typically have a psychology, PhD researcher fill this type of role. But we'd love for you to come out and interview. And, you know, they didn't hate what I had to say in my job talk.
How did that happen? So my first NIH grant that I got, I was in Australia and partnered with Purdue University because they were in the U.S. And it was easier to, you know, fund something from the U.S. government in the U.S. And I formed a partnership with Purdue through that grant. And when they opened up a new position, they called me and said, you know, we don't typically have a psychology, PhD researcher fill this type of role. But we'd love for you to come out and interview. And, you know, they didn't hate what I had to say in my job talk.|||这是怎么发生的？所以我的第一笔 NIH 资助是我在澳大利亚时获得的，并与普渡大学合作，因为他们在美利坚合众国。在美国资助美国政府的项目更容易，你知道的。我通过那笔资助与普渡大学建立了合作关系。当他们开放新职位时，他们打电话给我说：“你知道的，我们通常没有拥有心理学博士学位的研究人员来担任此类角色。但我们希望你能出来面试。”而且，你知道的，他们并不讨厌我在求职演讲中所说的话。
So we were able to forge a partnership. And Purdue has had the Center for Human Animal Bonds since the late 1980s. So they have had a center focused on this for quite some time. They just haven't built in that psychology piece. So what are the big open questions? What are you looking at? What do you hope to do going forward well into the future? Well into the future.
So we were able to forge a partnership. And Purdue has had the Center for Human Animal Bonds since the late 1980s. So they have had a center focused on this for quite some time. They just haven't built in that psychology piece. So what are the big open questions? What are you looking at? What do you hope to do going forward well into the future? Well into the future.|||所以我们能够建立合作关系。普渡大学自 20 世纪 80 年代末以来就拥有人与动物纽带中心（Center for Human Animal Bonds）。所以他们有一个专注于此的中心相当长一段时间了。他们只是没有建立那个心理学部分。那么，有哪些重大的未解问题？你在关注什么？你希望在未来做得怎么样？展望未来。
Well, I hope that this field continues to grow. It is so much fun and it feels so meaningful. I mean, when you have people telling you that an animal saved their life and they would not be alive due to their mental health challenges, the ability to work with them to create data that shares their story through numbers, through science, it's just, it's so meaningful and it's so much fun. And I hope that I get to do that for many years to come. And I hope others do as well. So that's my passion and my goal.
Well, I hope that this field continues to grow. It is so much fun and it feels so meaningful. I mean, when you have people telling you that an animal saved their life and they would not be alive due to their mental health challenges, the ability to work with them to create data that shares their story through numbers, through science, it's just, it's so meaningful and it's so much fun. And I hope that I get to do that for many years to come. And I hope others do as well. So that's my passion and my goal.|||嗯，我希望这个领域继续发展。这太有趣了，而且感觉非常有意义。我的意思是，当有人告诉你动物救了他们的命，由于他们的心理健康挑战，他们将无法活下去时，能够与他们合作创建通过数字、科学分享他们故事的数据，这简直，太有意义了，也太有趣了。我希望在未来的许多年里我能做到这一点。我也希望其他人也能做到。这就是我的热情和我的目标。
And in terms of the specific questions, you know, my immediate next step is to continue to work with the veterans and service dogs. So we just received a five-year NIH grant to do a randomized clinical trial of the efficacy of service dogs for veterans and their family. So that will certainly keep us busy for a few years here. I'm really hoping to get that rigorous data on a clinical level to share with clinicians, with doctors, with insurance companies, with policy makers. That's our initial next step.
And in terms of the specific questions, you know, my immediate next step is to continue to work with the veterans and service dogs. So we just received a five-year NIH grant to do a randomized clinical trial of the efficacy of service dogs for veterans and their family. So that will certainly keep us busy for a few years here. I'm really hoping to get that rigorous data on a clinical level to share with clinicians, with doctors, with insurance companies, with policy makers. That's our initial next step.|||就具体问题而言，你知道的，我的下一步是继续与退伍军人和服务犬合作。因此，我们刚刚获得了为期五年的 NIH 资助，用于对退伍军人及其家属服务犬疗效进行随机临床试验。所以这肯定会让我们在这里忙碌几年。我真的很希望在临床层面上获得这些严谨的数据，以便与临床医生、医生、保险公司、政策制定者分享。这是我们最初的下一步。
And then kind of on a broader level, I have so many open questions. But to boil it down, I would say I'm excited about the physiology pieces. I think it's fascinating that we can objectively track different. when someone's with an animal versus without. You know, if we take, for example, the service dogs, we found that veterans who had a service dog had a different cortisol profile than those who didn't. So if we look at stress hormone physiology
And then kind of on a broader level, I have so many open questions. But to boil it down, I would say I'm excited about the physiology pieces. I think it's fascinating that we can objectively track different. when someone's with an animal versus without. You5 know, if we take, for example, the service dogs, we found that veterans who had a service dog had a different cortisol profile than those who didn't. So if we look at stress hormone physiology|||然后在更广泛的层面上，我有太多的未解问题。但归根结底，我想说我对生理学部分感到兴奋。我认为令人着迷的是，我们可以客观地追踪不同的结果。当某人与动物在一起与不在一起时。你知道，如果我们以服务犬为例，我们发现拥有服务犬的退伍军人与没有服务犬的退伍军人具有不同的皮质醇特征。所以如果我们看应激激素生理学
and see that it is significantly different when you have a service dog, that fascinates me, and that makes me ask questions about mechanisms. How does it work? Why does it work? And can we pursue that further? So the physiology is one piece. And then the second piece that I'd love to look into, which I would venture to say is less popular,
and see that it is significantly different when you have a service dog, that fascinates me, and that makes me ask questions about mechanisms. How does it work? Why does it work? And can we pursue that further? So the physiology is one piece. And then the second piece that I'd love to look into, which I would venture to say is less popular,|||并看到当你拥有一只服务犬时它有显著不同，这让我着迷，这让我提出关于机制的问题。它是如何工作的？为什么它有效？我们能进一步探讨吗？所以生理学是一部分。然后第二部分我想研究的东西，我敢说它不太受欢迎，
is that, you know, I think there's this drive for people because they are so passionate about it to have it be black and white to say this is so good for us. It's great for everyone. Sign everyone up. And what I'd love to see is more nuance to find out for who and under what circumstances this is best and how can we make it better. I don't think that you develop, if we think about drug trials as an example, you don't develop a drug, move on and say it's done. You know, you want to enhance it. You want to reduce side effects. You want to streamline it. And I want to be able to do that with our animal-assisted interventions. How can we make this the best for the human and for the animal? And I think if we're able to, you know, dig deeper, we'll be able to have more honest conversations
就是，你知道的，我认为人们有一种动力，因为他们对此充满热情，所以希望它是非黑即白的，认为这对我们太好了。这对每个人都好。把所有人都注册进来。而我希望看到的是更多细微的差别，弄清楚在什么情况下、对谁而言这是最好的，以及我们如何能把它做得更好。我不认为你在开发——如果我们以药物试验为例，你不会开发一种药物，然后就此罢休并说它完成了。你知道的，你会想要改进它。你想要减少副作用。你想要简化它。我也希望能够对我们的动物辅助干预措施做到这一点。我们如何才能为人类和动物实现最好的效果？我认为如果我们能够，你知道的，深入挖掘，我们将能够进行更诚实的对话
and make it a better process for everyone involved. Well, this has been really interesting. I've enjoyed talking to you, Dr. O'Hare. Thank you for joining us today. It was my pleasure. Thank you so much for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts, and please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association,
并为参与其中的每个人提供更好的流程。好的，这真的非常有趣。很高兴与您交谈，奥黑尔博士。感谢您今天加入我们。这是我的荣幸。非常感谢邀请我。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》以前的节目，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有意见或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学对话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪恩（Chris Condyenne）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学协会的
I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。